hey friends welcome back to deep dive if
you're new here then my name is ali and
it is usually my job to speak to authors
entrepreneurs creators and other
inspiring people about um how they got
to where they are and their strategies
and tools that we can learn from them to
apply to our lives on our shared journey
of living living our best lives all that
fun stuff uh but this episode is a
little bit different this is in fact a
solo q a so lots of you in the uh the
emails and in the youtube comments have
been requesting that i do a solo q a
where i just answer a bunch of questions
and so what we've done is that we have
asked our discord community yes we have
a completely free discord that you can
join link down below it's called the
friend zone and it's got lots of people
on it it's very active it's very fun but
we asked the discord community for
questions and we've categorized them
into the five main categories of a good
life i.e health wealth happiness love
and impact so i'm just going to be
blitzing through those questions if for
whatever reason you don't want to hear
me answering various questions then you
are more than welcome to watch another
episode or listen to another episode
where i interview someone interesting
but this is going to be a solo q a so
let's just dive straight into it so
let's start with the health category of
questions the first question is hey ali
how are you today really which is a good
question i feel like
the whole how are you thing people often
ask me like how are you and it's just
like i don't actually take that question
seriously so if i take the question
seriously how am i honestly i think i'm
pretty good i didn't get much sleep last
night i got maybe about four or five
hours of sleep something like that i had
some friends come over from america for
breakfast this morning that was awesome
so it's been like a very social day and
we're now filming this we're going to be
filming another video and then i'm
heading off to a startup founders
retreat later this evening uh so i feel
pretty good on that front one thing i
haven't taken so seriously in the last
week or two has been my health in the
sense that i haven't really done much
working out i haven't done much sports
uh life has sort of gotten in the way my
friend sheen was visiting from dubai and
so we ended up having loads of social
stuff going on which i think is fine but
i'd really like to get back into kind of
taking the health stuff a little bit
more seriously but broadly you know
can't really imagine life getting much
better there are a few things few things
we can work on like like anyone else but
like very feeling very privileged
feeling feeling very blessed all that
fun stuff all right next question is
what habits are you building
can suggest to others to live healthier
lives so there's a few specific things
that i'm working on number one i am
trying to actively improve my sleep so
i've been listening to a lot of episodes
of the hubermann lab podcast from andrew
huberman we'll link that down in the
video description and the show notes if
you want to check it out and he's got a
few episodes about kind of
evidence-based science science-backed
methods to have better sleep so the ones
that i'm trying personally are for
example sleeping and sleeping and waking
up at the same time every day not having
my phone with me that's pretty standard
stuff but also for example not having
caffeine in the afternoons after like 2
p.m because the half-life of caffeine is
pretty long also one thing i've started
doing is um turning the lights really
really dim because i've got dimmable
lights and lighting a candle because
apparently like overhead lights and the
way that they hit our eye retina and eye
and stuff our body responds to them in a
different way than like low hanging
lamps or candles because in theory our
circadian rhythms in our in our brain
are set by kind of ambient light
conditions and light coming from above
because if you can imagine back in our
evolutionary past we didn't have lamps
and lights and things and so we've
evolved to take advantage of overhead
light signals i.e the sun as a way of
kind of regulating our circadian rhythm
and apparently if you turn those lights
down and light a candle instead or turn
those lights off and light a candle
instead it sort of is a signal to the
brain that okay it's sleepy time now
anecdotally i do find that this is true
for me i find that you know lighting a
candle i feel like it helps me sleep
better it helps me feel a bit more like
okay now it's time to wind down it's
like i'm not having my phone with me
anymore that kind of stuff so sleep is a
big part of this another thing i'm
trying to vaguely take more seriously is
healthy eating i intended i intend this
year to get better at cooking which is a
bit of a long-term project but um the
sort of more proximal decision that i'm
making in terms of how i spend my
well money and time is by actually
aiming to order healthy options from
take away when i'm ordering options from
takeaway and trying to figure out what
are some sensible defaults because i
feel like and you know this is something
i've been i've been reading a bit about
that it's when we're having to make a
decision in the moment that we tend to
make bad decisions about our health
choices generally because in the moment
when we're making a decision we're
probably stressed we don't have much
time we're probably feeling a bit
overwhelmed and so it's very easy for
our i guess willpower
circuitry to get hijacked and the
solution to that is to figure out some
kind of system to have a few default
meals okay if i'm ordering from nando's
this is my meal if i'm ordering from a
poke house this is the meal that i'm
going to order um your mileage may vary
for that if you don't live off takeaways
like i do then you might want to i don't
have default meals when it comes to
cooking but just eating a little bit
healthier on that is something i'm
trying to do more of uh and thirdly
exercise i mean all of this stuff sleep
diet exercise it's all very standard
there's nothing particularly fancy here
but in terms of exercise what i'm aiming
to do is do weight training three times
a week and i'm trying to figure out a
way of incorporating playing squash and
badminton and tennis into my life as
well and that acts as my sort of cardio
in a fun way that doesn't necessarily
involve running although i'm kind of
thinking maybe i should take up running
i'll give it a go i sort of tried it a
bit and locked down and then my feet
started to hurt so i stopped doing it
but we've got a few people on the team
who are absolutely addicted to him and
obsessed with running so there must be
something to it so that's something i
might be i might be trying out so it's
all it's all very very standard stuff if
we're looking for more niche things i am
in the process of reading a book called
lifespan by david sinclair which is more
about the nitty-gritty of what we can do
to live longer lives um and you know
what sort of
you know calorie restriction and
intermittent fasting and mediterranean
diet and i'm sort of dabbling with
exploring that kind of stuff when it
comes to living a healthier life and i'm
also looking into these things like you
know for example i take a brain care
supplement called heights which is
basically a glorified multivitamin that
has blueberry extract and these other
things that allegedly have some amount
of evidence behind them that kind of
help
increase our nutritional or reduce our
nutritional deficiencies i also invest
in the company and i'm mates with the
founder and stuff and they're cool
people so i'm taking a deep dive into
this idea of brain care and what are the
things that we need what are the
ingredients that we need to make our
kind of minds healthier happier that
kind of vibe so those are just a few
things off the top of my head
okay uh next question what has been the
biggest recurring blocker either
mentally or physically to staying
productive and achieving your goals okay
so i think the biggest blocker
to staying productive and achieving my
goals has is is that
kind of this idea of
doing lots of little things rather than
a few big things
so
for example one of my major goals for
the year is to write my book and finish
my book and the way that i do that is by
having blocks of uninterrupted time for
deep work
but
because this is a goal that's like
important but not massively urgent it
always feels like almost every day there
is something more urgent that rocks up
like
oh we need to have this sort of meeting
or oh we need to film this sort of video
or oh this friend has come over from the
other side of the world therefore i
should probably have breakfast with them
or oh okay cool i guess i need to do
this thing and it's like i'm okay with
like there being exceptions to the deep
work thing but it there are so many
exceptions that it has almost become a
norm that i don't get my time for deep
work in the mornings for writing my book
and i find that for most people as well
like generally the way we achieve our
goals
you know there's an idea that paul
graham talks about in one of his blog
posts i think i think that's him the
maker versus the manager schedule now if
you're a manager the way you operate is
in half an hour chunks because the point
of a manager is to delegate things and
to make sure the people that they're
delegating things to are doing the
things on time but if the manager is the
one setting the schedule what what ends
up happening is that the makers i the
people that need large amounts of
uninterrupted time for deep work
can't like struggle to make that time
because there's always these little half
an hour meetings sort of throughout
throughout the calendar and i think for
most of us when we think of the goals
that we want to achieve they're probably
around being a maker rather than being a
manager and therefore require these
large uninterrupted blocks of time so
the way that i'm trying to solve this
personally is telling everyone in the
team that look before 1 pm i'm not going
to do anything i'm not going to be
involved in any team meetings and then
you can have me from like 1 till 6 pm if
you want me for meetings and things like
that and that has been good in terms of
protecting that time in the morning i've
also been finding on the advice of my
editor rachel that actually writing at
night time and actually having a deep
work block for two hours at night is
also totally fine i also find it very
helpful to use time for some times when
i'm on the train for example to just
bust out the ipad or the macbook or even
a physical journal and just write
sometimes if i have to be like for
example if i have to be in cambridge
tomorrow for an orthodontist appointment
which i do i'll probably go tonight and
stay in a hotel by myself so that
i can wake up early in the morning grab
breakfast and then do some deep work
then or even at nighttime like there's
something around changing up the
atmosphere uh changing up the
environment and just sort of making it
more of a ritual that okay this is now
my time for deep work that i find
personally quite helpful but it's really
kind of the interruption of those little
blocks of time that i find particularly
tricky yeah that's probably the biggest
blocker okay next question what do you
do for leisure and how often do you do
these things
so what do i do for leisure i mean i
dabble with singing piano and guitar and
i just pick those up and sing whenever i
feel like it as you might have noticed
if you watch my daily vlogs if you don't
know their thing i do daily vlogs on my
my vlog channel that'll be linked down
in the video description and the show
notes if you want to check it out but
i'm always kind of singing around
throughout the day sometimes i'll pick
up the guitar on the piano and bash out
some chords sometimes i'll put on a
karaoke track sometimes i'll just sing
by myself so singing is a big part of my
leisure time and i just do it here and
there another thing i do is i like to
play sports so you know there's a local
badminton thing at the local leisure
center that i have gone to once in the
last several weeks because i have had
stuff on i need to make more of a
default in my calendar this is protected
time for playing badminton i like to
play squash i've got a friend called
pablo who runs a company called co-leap
which i've also invested in and he and i
play squash every other week hanging out
with friends going out for dinner
breakfast with people having coffee it's
often that sort of stuff i do kind of
want to get back into video games i was
you know i've talked about this before a
big fan of world of warcraft back in the
day and then when i had covert for 10
days just before christmas i ended up
getting really into horizon zero dawn
and i want to play eldon ring i want to
play horizon forbidden west might
kind of re-get my gaming pc and do
something with that i think i do kind of
want to make video gaming part of my
life uh currently it's not if i can make
the time i guess i also read i read
quite a lot i tend to read fiction in
bed before sleeping and i tend to read
nonfiction during the day listen to
podcasts that sort of thing so that's my
leisure
next question what do you think about
meditation right so meditation i've
dabbled with meditation on and off for a
few years now i think the most i've
gotten through is like 10 or 12 days of
sam harris's 30-day course on waking up
and then something gets in the way and i
forget to do it and then i break the
habit and i don't really get it myself
yet because i haven't done it for long
enough to make the practice worthwhile
and i know a bunch of people and
basically every successful person who
i've ever heard on a podcast has some
kind of meditation practice
there is definitely something to it i
just haven't really given it the time
that it needs
one thing that someone has suggested is
kind of just doing a three day of your
passenger meditation retreat and just
seeing what happens and using that as a
bit of a forcing function to
um actually do the thing that i care
about and kind of thinking about that
point more broadly i've got a friend
called called chris sparks he used to be
my productivity coach back in the day
but he runs a company called the forcing
function and basically his whole
philosophy of productivity and success
in getting things done and all the stuff
that we actually want to do is that you
know we all have these things that we
want to do like you know things like
taking our health more seriously or
working out a bit more or cooking or
learning a language or learning a
musical instrument but it's so hard to
make time for this stuff in our busy
day-to-day lives that what we need to do
is incorporate some kind of forcing
function into that
a thing that forces us to do the thing
so for example getting a personal
trainer and pre-paying for 10 sessions
in advance is a forcing function in that
in general it forces you it nudges you
in the direction of doing a thing that
you know you want to do i work out more
for example set like setting a rule for
yourself like i've had a rule for myself
which is that i've kind of lapped on but
i set a rule for myself that i'm not
allowed to order takeaway if i'm with
friends
and therefore that is in a way a forcing
function a systemic forcing function
that should theoretically force me to
cook now this worked for the first three
months of the year but then you know
time and everything else and whoops and
then i stopped taking that particular
rule seriously but i'm all about like
trying to figure out where is the
forcing function i can add to my life
where is the systemic change i can make
that will make time for this thing
and i guess coming back to the point
about meditation i don't yet have a
forcing function in my life for
meditation because it's not just not
something i've thought is important
enough for me to that well for me to
actually build a forcing function into
but it might happen at some point next
we have is your current daily routine
your ideal one what would you change
i actually think like on the days where
my daily routine is not interrupted by
other stuff it's it's pretty good so
this is what my daily routine tends to
look like it hasn't for the last two
weeks that sheen's been around because
like social stuff has taken hold but
before that uh essentially it was wake
up at seven o'clock in the morning do a
workout at 7 30 7 30 to 8 30 is workout
time 8 30 to 9 is sort of faffing and
like grabbing a coffee and showering
time and then from nine until 12 30 with
me by book writing time where i would
just be sitting down doing deep work
gordon my videographer might be around
some of the days willem one of our
writers might be around some of the days
just to riff some ideas off of but
generally nine till 12 30 book book time
where maybe i'll interrupt it by going
to a local coffee shop and grabbing a
coffee and coming back in then 12 30 to
1 p.m traveling to the studio then 1 pm
to 2 p.m is sort of an office hours
block where i have lunch and anyone in
the team can chat to me about anything
that they need me to unblock them on and
then 2 till 6 is sort of the work time
where i am at in the hands of the team
so whether that's recording a podcast or
filming a video or attending a meeting
to revamp our part-time youtuber academy
curriculum
or whatever and then at 6 pm that is the
end of the official quote work day and
then in theory i do some kind of sports
or something in the evening or hang out
with friends or even just spend time by
myself
that has been my daily routine for the
last few weeks outside of like social
stuff happening and i think that's
pretty ideal like that seems to be a
really solid routine for this season of
my life and yeah on that note i think
actually having a routine that you
follow attempting to create a routine
forever is probably a bad idea but
actually trying to create a routine just
be like hey hey just for this next
season of my life for the next few weeks
two months this is the routine that i'm
going to try out i'm going to experiment
and as long as it serves me then i will
continue the routine and when it stops
serving me then i will stop continuing
the routine and just being totally okay
to change my mind on that sort of thing
final question in health the business
has expanded fast with a lot of moving
parts what processes or tools do you use
to manage your mental health and avoid
burnout honestly the biggest one for me
to avoid burnout has actually been
journaling anytime i find myself feeling
a bit like ugh about the business i
recognize that as like a pre-burnout
feeling and then i think okay as a
matter of priority i need to sit down
with a pen and paper and a journal these
days i use the leuchtturm 1917 a5 dot
grid notebook with a lamy swift pen if
anyone's interested i just sit down with
a journal for several hours if i can and
just basically write out what my
thoughts are and why i think i'm feeling
that way and how i can change that and
what the action points are
and recently
i've been feeling like i do this quite a
lot last week i happened to be in
cambridge and i happened to have four
hours to myself in the morning in a
hotel room and i just sort of sat in the
bar downstairs having a hotel breakfast
and just wrote about 25 pages worth of
journalingy stuff and i realized that
you know a bunch of things i've been
feeling about the youtube channel and
the business and you know to what extent
we were optimizing for making money
rather than optimizing for helping
people and what effect that had on kind
of my own kind of views towards a
business and feeling burnt out and all
that stuff and i found that really
helpful because it gave me action points
that i could then change and i think
that's that's that for me is the key to
avoiding burnout it's like recognizing
that feeling of like ugh and whenever i
have that feeling of ugh with anything
that i'm doing i take a step back and
think okay
how am i complicit in creating this
feeling of uh and what can i change
about my situation to make this less of
an uh kind of feeling so that would be
what i would i would suggest okay next
we have a few questions in the category
of wealth why did you decide to write a
book
okay
so to answer this properly we have to
keep in mind a quote that is famously
attributed to jp morgan which is that a
man always has two reasons for doing
something a good reason and the real
reason
so what is my good reason for writing a
book a good reason would be that
it's fun a good reason would be that
it's you know a thing that will help me
get my ideas into the world and
potentially help people a good reason
would be that it would be an interesting
challenge a good reason would be that
it'll be good kind of good for my brand
and good for longevity of the brand and
all that kind of stuff then we start to
think okay so those are the good reasons
what about the real reasons like what is
that what are the selfish motives
underneath that that really lead me to
wanting to write a book and i suspect
you know these are tied in with the with
the other with the other reasons you
know part of it is i am concerned that
the life of a youtuber is not a very
long life in terms of the longevity of
the career but i know that the life of a
book author is like a very a career that
has longevity like i can imagine being
in my 50s and still wanting to write
books so there's something about that
that feels like okay cool this feels
like a good career that i can do for the
next like four decades of my life
without it being like oh my god 50 year
old man suddenly continuing to make
tick-tocks like hey friends welcome back
to the channel or whatever as kind of as
the world changes i suspect the writing
of books is a thing that will not
particularly change another reason is
that i think one of the nice things
about having a book is that it gives you
an air of legitimacy so right now i am
like the youtuber guy
previously i used to be the doctor
youtuber guy and youtuber guy to me
feels like not very legitimate i guess
because i've kind of been kind of grown
up in a sort of did a fancy medical
degree at a fancy university worked in a
very prestigious traditional job so
maybe part of me wants that indicator of
prestige that i'm a published author i'm
a best-selling published author and that
kind of thing maybe i feel adds more
legitimacy and like gravitas to my brand
and therefore helps the business succeed
over the long term um i think those are
like the more selfish reasons for
writing the book but like genuinely
if it wasn't fun i wouldn't do it like i
really enjoy the process of writing a
book it feels like an interesting
challenge i'm kind of treated i'm trying
to approach it in the spirit of play
rather than in the spirit of work and i
think i think that's working next
question what is the single best side
hustle or business to start as a
teenager honestly i think it's anything
that will help you make money while
leveling up useful skills so what are
useful skills useful skills are skills
that you can apply to future businesses
so for example knowing how to sell
knowing how to write knowing how to
copyright knowing how to build a product
knowing how to code these are all things
that i think really help further down
the line and so if i were a teenager
what i mean the business i would start
is i would become a solidity web 3
developer so that i could program on the
ethereum blockchain and that would be
such a no-brainer because the crypto
space is absolutely exploding still and
as a teenager i'd be i'd have so much
spare time on my hands trust me
teenagers have tons and tons and tons of
spare time on their hands i'd be able to
learn to code fairly quickly and then
i'll be able to potentially create a
cryptic product or join a crypto startup
when no one really cares about how old i
am that would be the thing that i do
because i think there's sort of that's
the next next big wave but once i've
done that i would try and create some
sort of software product maybe in the
crypto space maybe not and try and sell
actively sell it to businesses who have
money to spend on those sorts of
software products so maybe i'd create
tools for creators who have money or
businesses who have money or something
like that because even if the thing
doesn't succeed
by virtue of trying to build that
business i would have learned all of the
skills that would be really helpful for
a business that might succeed further
down the line next question how did you
decide what a levels to take i don't
want to be locked in if i decide to
change career path later
honestly no one gives a [ __ ] what a
levels you do beyond like university
admissions i mean i knew i wanted to go
to med school so the a levels were
obvious biology chemistry physics maths
i did english literature for as and
dropped fa2
that was pretty standard if i wanted to
get a job anywhere else no one would
care what a levels i had so don't worry
about your a-level choices if you want
to change career paths later in life
it's not a thing that's really going to
hold you back unless you decide i don't
know i want to become an economist etc
etc then you start working at a bank and
then at the age of 45 you decide you
want to be a doctor at that point maybe
one of the requirements will be
chemistry a level in which case you can
just do the chemistry level because it's
not that hard you can just
teach it to yourself but it's a decision
you don't need to overthink i think
choose your a-level choices based on
what you think you want your career path
to be or at least what you want to study
at university and your pro your ideal
career path will probably change over
time as you get more data points next
question what is your advice for people
who aren't following a clear trajectory
right out of college at university i
feel pressured to know what i want to do
and follow the ladder yeah i mean we all
feel that pressure to some degree or
another um depending on what sort of
influences you have in your life
depending on how much your parents care
about you getting a traditional career
broadly my advice would be that because
it's those skills that you learn that
will compound over time rather than the
fact that you're in a traditional career
and also when you're in your 30s when
you have responsibilities you can't
really take the risks that you could
when you were in your 20s so everyone
says this you know take risks in your
20s it's all good like you know try and
keep your expenses low when you're in
your early 20s you can backpack around
the world and live in hostels and you
probably won't care when you're when
you're in your late 20s your early 30s
you probably won't want to do that so
like automatically the sort of risks
that you can take and the sort of money
that you need to take those risks
massively changes as you get older so my
only piece of advice would be i mean if
you feel the pressure to go into a
traditional career question where that
pressure is coming from like why do you
really want to do that what are the
reasons are those reasons your own or
those are those reasons for other people
and
are you going to be optimizing for
learning when you're in your early 20s
or do you instead want to optimize for
trying to make money in a traditional
career path honestly i think for most
people if you care about making money
learning lots of stuff and starting your
own business is a way more efficient to
get rich than joining a traditional job
like becoming a doctor or a lawyer or a
management consultant like there's
another ways you get rich those are
those are the ways that you continue to
make money by trading your time for
money for an employer that's making like
vastly larger sums of money than you are
as an individual because you're an
employee and there is a limit to how
much you can earn as an employee whereas
as an entrepreneur there's almost no
limit to the amount you can earn as an
entrepreneur and the way you get there
is by having a bit of entrepreneurial
spirit and by learning skills when
you're young so learn those skills take
the risks learn those skills but yeah
it's hot and finally in the wealth
category how do you create a content
engine or pipeline for managing your
content and consistently uploading to
different platforms oh that's easy
there's this thing called goals law
which is any complex system evolves any
complex system that works
evolves from a simple system that works
and so you start off with a simple
system upload one video at a time
cool easy now now that you can do that
figure out how to upload one video a
week
cool once you can do that you realize
that okay i need a system for that
writing filming editing publishing these
are all like different things so okay
i'm going to create the minimum viable
system for that maybe using an app like
notion or even using pen and paper in
post-it notes or the kanban method or
all these different ways of managing
projects
then you're like okay cool i'm pretty
comfortable making one video a week now
what do i need to add to the system to
make it two videos a week
cool sorted now what do i need to do to
make it two videos a week and one
newsletter a week
okay cool sorted now what i need to do
to make two videos a week one newsletter
a week and repurpose some of the stuff
into tick tocks and instagram okay
sorted what you don't want to do is try
and do all of this from day one you want
to start simple you want to slowly build
up the system over time uh and then it's
pretty straightforward to end up with a
system that works
that would be what i would suggest let's
move on to happiness
question number one within that category
is what is your favorite quote
probably it's a quote from derek sivers
book anything you want 40 lessons for a
new kind of entrepreneur i'm just
looking around to see if i have it in
the studio to hand probably not but
there's a quote from that that really
resonated with me in 2016 and that i've
recently in my little journaling session
last week actually figured out that i
needed to hear that quote again for a
bit of context derek sivers great guy um
he's now a friend of mine internet
friend of mine we've met a few times in
real life actually twice once or twice
something like that anyway uh he has a
really great blog he used to run a
company called ct baby sold it for like
20 million something like that back in
the day and now just travels around the
world living the good life writing books
that kind of stuff he wrote a book which
is sort of like a
you know almost a different approach to
entrepreneurship and in one of his
chapters he says never forget why you're
really doing what you're doing or rather
always remember why you're why you're
doing what you're doing are you happy
are you having fun are you helping
people are they happy are you profitable
isn't that enough i often think back to
that quote of like are you helping
people are you happy are they happy are
you profitable because like those are
the things those are the things that
matter helping people while having fun
and making enough money to
to survive
beyond that that's actually enough
that's like a pretty sick life if you
can be serving others
while you're happy yourself while
they're happy and while you're making
enough money to survive that's like
pretty solid
and i often think back to that quote
whenever i find myself in this treadmill
of like wanting more and more and more i
need more money i need more fans i need
more followers i need more subscribers i
need more this and that it's like never
you know always remember why you're
doing what you're doing
are you helping people are you happy are
they happy are you profitable isn't that
enough that's probably my favorite quote
thank you derek sivers for that one all
right next what's your main source of
happiness slash what are the things you
value most in life okay
i i wouldn't say i have a main source of
happiness because i think happiness
broadly is a default state at least
that's the way i think of it maybe i'm
kind of thinking a lot here but anyway
happiness is a default state happiness
is the default state that we have when
we come into the world when we're kids
we're just always happy happy all the
time but the things that lead to
unhappiness are kind of the salient
negatives in our lives where we're doing
something that
doesn't vibe with our own values we are
doing something because other people are
telling us to do the thing we don't have
autonomy over our own time and what
we're doing
uh where we've got these things that we
have to do that we just really don't
enjoy and that we aren't making fun
i think those are the things that lead
to unhappiness
and so really for me the source of
happiness is to try and eliminate
sources of unhappiness so for example
let's talk about money you know money is
one of those things everyone says money
doesn't buy unhappiness sorry money
doesn't buy happiness
but it does you know it doesn't solve
all your problems but it does solve your
money problems like not having enough
money is a source of unhappiness but
having lots of money is not a source of
happiness in a way
by making money
and being sufficiently kind of passive
income as it were
you're removing concerns about money in
theory from as being a detractor in your
life great what's the next thing time
having control of your time you know
doesn't necessarily make you happy but
not having control of your time makes
you unhappy cool so then how can i
optimize my life for actually having
control over my time
and when i find myself feeling a bit
unhappy feeling it down feeling like oh
and i look at my calendar and think okay
is this really the calendar that i would
like to have if i imagined my ideal life
what would my calendar look like and how
does it how is it different to what my
calendar currently looks like
and so if i were to answer what's the
source of your unhappiness
so sorry what's the biggest source of
your happiness it would be that i think
very hard about what are the possible
sources of my unhappiness and i work
work to eliminate those things from my
life i would say
also broadly my main source of happiness
i really enjoy what i'm doing day to day
i have great health well pretty good
health loving friends and family and a
good social life and stuff like honestly
it's really hard to imagine life going
much better and so another thing i often
remind myself of is like this is like
life is actually pretty sick the second
part of that question is what are the
things you value most in life
health number one freedom
fairly high on the list relationships
fairly high on the list
yeah doing things i enjoy probably those
are the things i value most in life all
right uh next question what is your
advice for embracing who you are as a
person okay so just think of thinking
out loud here this idea of who you are
as a person implied that who you are is
like implies that who you are is like a
fixed thing um when i'm not i'm not sure
that's the case
uh i think who we are is basically a
function of circumstances and
accidents of birth and who we happen to
hang out with when we were young and how
our parents treated us when we were
young broadly things that were outside
of our control and so what we become we
tend to not have chosen that for
ourselves it tends to be a result of
accidents and so part of my whole spiel
around self-improvement and like you
know is instead of be yourself choose
yourself choose the sort of person you
want to be and then take the actions
that's all that sort of person would
take to get to that place
but i think at the same time and this is
where the yin yang comes in the
middleweight comes in
uh there is also a balance of
self-acceptance which is sort of
thinking simultaneously
i am totally happy with who i am right
now and i'm fully accepting of that but
at the same time i also want to change i
also want to grow i also want to improve
along these things which are internally
driven rather than externally driven so
that would be my advice for embracing
who you are think about like well try
and try and accept it because it's like
who you are is like okay and the things
you want to change about yourself you
absolutely can change about yourself if
you want to if you don't want it that's
totally fine like great hunky-dory life
is good that kind of thing uh next
question do you ever feel like work or
daily life gets boring how do you make
sure to live life to the fullest
honestly no i i
i can't remember the last time i had the
feeling that like daily work or life was
boring i think because i always have
some kind of challenge some kind of
thing that i'm working towards or
working on or something new in my life
you know at one point working day in day
out as a doctor while doing youtube
videos in the evenings was kind of gone
a little bit boring but then i
outsourced my video editing and now i
suddenly had loads of free time and now
i learned how to grow business and now
the business challenge became the fun
thing that i was working on
then you know as my doctor career was
sort of winding out at the end of the
two years and that was starting to get a
bit boring because it was coveted time i
was on the same ward for eight months uh
it was all you know somewhat repetitive
but then the youtube channel was taking
off and then i started i got this book
thing that i was sort of started working
on and
it feels like at each stage any season
of my life there is a new challenge
something something to keep things
interesting and if i again i check in
with myself like if myself if i find
that every day is becoming samey and
it's becoming boring one of the great
things about being an entrepreneur being
a creative printer is that you've got
control over your own life you can do
what you want and so if i am getting
bored then that's just weird right
because i can do what i want like let me
do things that i find interesting and
honestly i haven't haven't felt the
feeling of boredom in a very very very
long time probably years i don't think i
felt the feeling of boredom since like
university properly um even since school
like yeah i just don't really get bored
because there's always so many
interesting things i could be doing uh
next question have you ever been through
analysis paralysis how did you slash do
you deal with it
yeah analysis paralysis it's very easy
to like overthink things and then just
not take action on them i think number
one knowing that that's a thing is
helpful for me uh and generally if i
have a new idea for something i'll have
a bias towards action let's just get the
thing done rather than spend ages
planning about how the thing will get
done and then not do the thing
ultimately i think another model that i
like is sort of this three-part model of
get going then get good and then get
smart and this is the thing i tell
creators as well like if you're starting
a youtube channel level one is get going
just like start making videos about
anything it doesn't matter like no one
cares and level two is get good actually
learn how to make good videos and then
level three is get smart get smart means
like figuring out your target audience
figuring out your niche figuring out
what you're gonna do figuring out how
you're gonna stand out and so many
people think level three when they're at
level zero they worry about what their
niche is going to be when they don't
know how to speak to a camera they don't
know how to make a good video it's sort
of like if you're an artist but you're
saying i'm not going to learn how to
paint until i figured out what my kind
of magnum opus is going to be or what my
kind of
piece that hangs up in the louvre is
going to be it's like being a writer and
saying i'm not i'm not going to start
writing until i figured out what my
best-selling book is going to be about
but because until i figure out what it's
about like i couldn't possibly start
writing
and i think i've seen that so many times
in my life where it's just like actually
just do the thing and you can always
improve and get better at the thing and
do the analysis over time and there's
another quote from a book traction that
i like which is that a strategy without
execution is just delusion or
just hallucination you know words like
that strategy without execution is
hallucination i think start with
execution start doing the thing and then
you can always add in the strategy to it
later and that's a thing that i've i
really believe to be true and i do find
you know with the business as the
business grows and we become more
analytical in our in our approach to
things you know this is the problem with
having a big business a bigger business
is that things just move a bit slower
and the challenge with a bigger business
is that you want to retain that that
fast-moving energy while also
understanding that you've got loads of
people around so for example a few weeks
ago we had the idea hey let's do a daily
vlog and one of the great things that
came out of that was that we were like
you know what we'll just do it from next
week and we'll figure it out as we go
along and we had gordon who is our
videographer and head of production who
was really like had that
fast-moving entrepreneurial mindset to
be like you know what we don't need to
analyze the hell out of this for years
before we do it let's just do it and
we'll change course over time i think
that level of like thinking when it
comes to this sort of stuff is how we
stay how we as a business avoid analysis
paralysis if it's something like you
know we've made the mistake in the past
of thinking oh we should totally do this
course thing but like oh i guess before
we think about it we should do this we
should do this we should do that and
before you know it six months have
passed and the course hasn't been filmed
whereas if i was just doing it on my own
with one team member we would have
filmed the course in a weekend and it
would have been pretty good and often
our perfectionism in trying to get
something to 100 quality means that we
don't do it rather than just doing it to
98 quality which we might have done if
we just moved faster so i do keep that
in mind um but i think kind of the model
of just do the thing and adjust over
time
is the way that you get over analysis
paralysis don't wait until you know what
you're going to make videos about before
you start making videos don't wait until
you've got a theme for your podcast
before you start recording don't wait
until you know what your book's gonna be
about before you start writing on the
internet just start doing it and
the the strategy will follow and then
final question on the happiness category
is what is your biggest motivation slash
what are you aiming for right now yeah
that's the thing um i mean proximal
goals i guess is i want to write my book
and i want to be proud of it
and that's a thing that i'm aiming for
more you know
distal goals okay i guess
the really the way i think about it is
there are some games that we play that
are finite games and there are some
games that we play that are infinite
games a finite game is played with the
intention of winning the game you know
something like football is a finite game
you kick them all around you've got 90
minutes you need to score there's a
winner there's a loser that kind of
thing it's a very finite game an
infinite game is a game that you play
for the purpose of continuing to play
the game so for example there's no
purpose in having dinner with friends or
having like a weekly i don't know weekly
catch up with the boys that kind of
thing the purpose of that is to continue
doing the thing it's to continue playing
the infinite game rather than to win or
to complete the game and i feel like
right now i am genuinely playing my
infinite game in that i'm spending my
time doing the stuff that i love with
people that i like i enjoy hanging out
with i was gonna say people i love but
that sounds weird cause i've got three
of my team members behind the camera
right now and that sounds sounds a bit
odd um but i'm doing stuff that i love
with people that i like working with i'm
spending my time reading writing and
teaching
and doing podcast interviews honestly i
can't imagine anything i'd rather be
doing like this is my infinite game this
is the thing that working to get to a
point where i could just spend my time
reading writing and teaching and now
this is what i'm doing like i'm i'm
already living my end game i'm already
playing my infinite game
and so given that i'm already playing my
infinite game by nature the objective of
the infinite game is to continue playing
the game and so my motivation my goals
in life
now
around the stuff that i'm spending my
time doing is i just want to be able to
continue doing this stuff so how do i
make this stuff sufficiently successful
that it allows me to continue doing it
how do i lower the bar uh kind of lower
my own standards so that i don't feel
overly analytical and get paralyzed by
perfectionism so that i can continue
doing the thing how do i explore topics
and stuff in a way that i have freedom
to so that i can kind of make the stuff
that i want to make without being overly
worried about it it's just about being
able to continue to play this infinite
game and i think when you get to a point
where the game you are playing is the
game you want to be playing seemingly
forever that's a pretty good place to be
and at that point striving for more and
more and more is probably
counterproductive because actually
optimizing for
continuing to play the game feels feels
to be the wave to me at least to be the
way forward we have a few questions
about love
uh number one who is your celebrity
crush or used to be if you don't have
one now
celebrity crush
i mean always had a bit of a crush on
emma watson i mean who doesn't had a bit
of a crush on um gabrielle from
gabriella from high school musical who
doesn't um
alia butt the bollywood actress bit of a
crush on her don't really do major
celebrity crushes tbh
it's not really been a major thing in my
life but yeah i guess those three come
to mind okay next what qualities do you
look for in a partner personally or
professionally oh okay those are two
very different things oh actually i'm
not sure they are i actually think the
qualities i look for in a romantic
partner are fairly similar to the
qualities i'd look for in a business
partner except in a romantic partner i'd
want them to be
cute and i want them to be a girl
whereas those are not requirements in a
business partner but i think in a
business partner like yeah in a way i i
sometimes talk to my current girlfriend
about this it's like in a way a romantic
partner is a co-founder
for the business unit that we call a
family
and a lot of people say i've read a
bunch of books about like marriage and
love and relationships and things and
they say that once you get married and
you start having kids
it really does become like you and your
partner are running a business together
and how do you run this business
effectively in a way that keeps everyone
happy and that
leads you to your aim of like having fun
having a meaningful life and raising
good kind healthy kids i think so then i
think okay what are the qualities of a
co-founder number one i think
communication kindness is all the basic
stuff the stuff i look for is all very
basic but i think for me one thing that
maybe is different to a lot of my
friends who have spoken to about this is
that in a business partner and also in a
romantic partner i want them to have
co-founder energy i i want to feel like
they can go toe-to-toe with me and that
me and them are like on on an equal
footing i think part of that comes from
me sort of
wanting to admire or significantly
respect something about them wanting to
look up to them in some aspects wanting
to feel like
partnering up with this person
is actually a win-win because it also
makes me a better person
i don't want to feel like i'm
partnering with someone who doesn't have
that energy or that
vibe or that intellect
something we would to be able to go
toe-to-toe with me as a co-founder would
that is probably the thing
that i look for is this someone who i
genuinely respect and could respect as a
co-founder for a business if that's a
yes then great if that's a no then then
it's a nugget
and next question is how can you handle
rejection yeah i mean just do it time
rejection is always better than regret
that's that phrase the pain of rejection
is always
is the the pain of regret is always way
worse than the pain of rejection i think
as a guy in the society that we live in
guys are still the ones expected to make
romantic advances rather than girls
and so as a guy you kind of just have to
get used to dealing with rejection and
asking people out and they'll say no and
that's fine you realize that life moves
on it's not the end of the world who
cares the way i think of it is that like
rejection is
really doing me a favor if i ask someone
out and they say no then fantastic that
saves me a lot of time a lot of time in
going on dates with them maybe even
being in a relationship where it
wouldn't have worked out because they
didn't want to be with me in the first
place it's a big rejection is a big
time-saving device that's at least how i
think about it and then we have a few
more questions about impact so question
one is how do you how to stay motivated
during the book writing process yeah i
think that's the thing i think number
one is to figure have a you know this is
a basic advice like have a good reason
why you're doing the thing and actually
this is stuff i have been thinking about
recently like selfish goals versus
service goals a selfish goal is i want
to become a new york times bestseller a
service goal is i want this book to
change at least one person's life or
change their approach to work a selfish
goal is i want to make a million dollars
a selfless goal or a service goal is i
want to help a million people become
happier this is something very inspiring
when i interviewed mo gowda the
happiness expert and his his mission is
to make 1 billion people in the world
happier there's something really cool
about that there's something about that
that i really like so partly the way i
stay motivated with the book writing
process is to remember the service which
is to
for this book to help at least one
person change their approach to work in
a positive way but also to make the
process for me as fun as possible to
approach it with a spirit of play so
that i'm doing it for its own sake and
that even if
no one read the book
the act of writing it would still have
been a worthwhile thing to do anything
that i enjoyed and a thing that i looked
back on with fondness
and when it becomes not that i remind
myself that hang on this is supposed to
be fun to treat it sincerely rather than
seriously and to really
sort of
approach it more with the spirit of play
with lightness and ease rather than with
the spirit of work that this thing is a
job what do you envision the impact of
the book will be on students i don't
know envision is a strong word i hope
the impact of the book is that it will
help people
in a small way change their approach to
work
so that you know work doesn't have to be
suffering work doesn't have to be this
thing that you grind away at work can be
this thing that like and you can control
it to an extent
that genuinely energizes you so that in
a way you get to the end of the work day
feeling more energized than when you
started and you can then use that energy
on your hopes dreams passions ambitions
hanging out with friends or even just
chilling out like but it gives you
energy in the tank and i want people to
change their relationship with work so
that like they recognize that that is a
thing that can happen and that's kind of
what i've been doing for the last like
ten years of my life or probably not ten
like like five six seven years of my
life and it's great it means
productivity takes care of itself it's
like effortless productivity when your
work is so energizing that you don't
need to worry about to-do lists and
hacks and stuff to be more productive so
i hope it'll change people's minds or
you know impact people in that sense uh
next question you always talk about the
e-myth revisited how do you and the team
apply the book to the business so the
e-myth revisited is a book by michael
gerber and it's about why small
businesses fail and how to avoid the
failure of small businesses it's a book
i recommend everyone who is at the point
where they are they're making enough
money that they can hire people but they
either they either haven't hired anyone
yet or they've hired people and have
done a bad job of delegating things so
probably not applicable to most of the
audience of this podcast because i
imagine most of you don't have people
that you're
on the verge of hiring or have hired but
if you are in that position then it's a
really good book in terms of how to
delegate things more effectively how to
you know it recognizes the difference
between being a technician a manager and
an entrepreneur and these are the three
different hats that entrepreneurs or
business owners wear the technician is
the person baking the pies the manager
is the person making the systems and the
entrepreneur is the person coming up
with the ideas and when you recognize
that these three are separate roles you
recognize that when you get to a certain
point you probably don't want to be
spending all your time doing the
technician thing even though that's why
you started the business it's why
operating a coffee shop is very
different from knowing how to make good
coffee it's why running a restaurant is
very different from for example knowing
how to cook the manager and the
entrepreneur needs to be added to the
technician to make a good business and
that's where a lot of people struggle
and fail and so really it's been the
early applications of that book early on
in our journey sort of about two years
ago that really helped me get over the
fear of delegation and get more good and
more okay at delegating stuff all right
next question how do you decide what
book to read next do you have sources
you turn for for recommendations and how
do you know if the book is right for you
or not yeah in terms of book
recommendations i always have way too
many recommendations like i follow
people on twitter i subscribe to a bunch
of email newsletters people in real life
recommend books to me people on my
podcast when i interview them
recommended books to me people that i
have zoom calls with because i admire
them on the internet i want to be
friends recommend books to me so i
always have a never-ending list of books
that i want to read and once i finished
one or once i've got everything out of
it i'll often just like willy-nilly
decide how what do i feel like doing
flick through my kindle to all the books
that i bought and i'll just start i'll
just start reading the next one that's
if i'm approaching it in an ad hoc way
um a more like legit way of doing it if
i'm reading a bit more seriously if i'm
if i'm considering whether or not i want
to read a book or not i'll often look up
a book summary if that summary is
available on short form shortform.com
forward slash ali if you want an
affiliate link short form is my favorite
book summary source genuinely i will
look up the book and see if it's
available in short form and if it is
i'll read the summary and if i vibe with
the summary then i'll read the book if
it's not available in short form then
i'll just look up a summary on google
someone will have written a summary
somewhere and that'll help me decide
whether it's for me sometimes i'll just
buy the audio book and start listening
to it and see okay do i vibe with this
and if after about half an hour i'm half
an hour of listening to it at 2.5 times
speed i'm still enjoying it then i know
the book is probably for me okay next
question what is the single most
life-changing book you've read probably
the four-hour work week by tim ferriss
read it when i was 17 or 18 and that
changed my approach to career
entrepreneurship life the principles in
it are fairly obvious now because it's
this but it was a very sort of novel
book at the time that it was released
around about 2007. but reading that book
in when i was 17 and like 2011 time
round about then was just absolutely
game changing so that would be the book
that's most changed my life and the next
question is what are the best books for
business oriented goals probably the
e-myth revisited and traction and
over-subscribed those are the three
books the e-myth revisited by michael
gerber traction by gina wickman and
oversubscribed by daniel priestley that
would be my recommendation alrighty i
think that is it for this q a thank you
very much for tuning in if you're
watching or listening to this as always
there'll be links to all of the stuff
that i mentioned down in the video
description or in the show notes um if
you haven't seen i have a vlog channel
on youtube if you would like to be up to
date with the daily weekday vlogs on my
second channel uh that's been going for
the last three weeks and we are going to
be continuing it for the foreseeable
future so you can see what i get up to
day to day um but otherwise thank you so
much for watching if you enjoyed this
episode please do leave us a review on
itunes that's like the place where you
leave reviews for podcasts or on spotify
if you're listening to this we'll put
links to those in the video description
and the show notes as well that would
mean a lot otherwise thank you so much
for watching um
yeah see you next time bye